economía en directo América de Franz 24
Luis Méndez Zurich nuevamente en nuestro
estudio para hablar del Día de Acción de
Gracias Luis en Estados Unidos porque es
que es un evento que como bien lo indica
se lleva para agradecer todo lo que se
tiene y una manera de festejarlos con
una tradicional cena el elemento
principal de esta cena es el pavo y
podría decirse que esta será la primera
celebración de Acción de Gracias
medianamente similar a las que se vivían
previo a la pandemia con reuniones
familiares grandes y además viajes sin
embargo un tema que preocupa a los
ciudadanos es el encarecimiento que han
tenido los productos en la víspera de la
celebración por ejemplo de acuerdo con
Ford puro el precio promedio de una cena
familiar para 10 personas se ha
incrementado un 20% En comparación con
el año pasado que a su vez ya había
registrado un aumento de 14% si lo
comparamos con el año 2020 Pero también
es importante señalar que el aumento de
los ingredientes para dicha cena había
sido de preocupación para las
autoridades que estimaron el aumento
Hace algunos meses entre un 9,5 y un
10,5 Esto sí lo tomamos de acuerdo con
la agencia de noticias ap pero la cadena
de noticias al jazir a la catarín cita
datos del índice de presión al
consumidor de la oficina de estadísticas
laborales y refleja que estos Podrían
haber alcanzado un 13% para este año sin
embargo también hay que tomar en cuenta
que se están produciendo muchos viajes
gracias a las vacunas también los
cambios a nivel laboral que permiten
ahora un mayor porcentaje del
teletrabajo y todo ello incluido para un
aumento en los viajes respecto al año
anterior Luis vamos ahora a hablar de
china porque ese país afronta altos
niveles de contagio de eco-19 Así es se
sabe que la nación registró una cifra
récord superando los 30.000 contagios en
las últimas horas una situación que hace
crecer el temor de un nuevo impacto
económico a nivel global a partir
bloqueos que se están registrando en esa
nación vale decir que china ha estado
trabajando para controlar los contagios
a lo largo del presente año con cierres
focalizados en algunas ciudades
recordemos el caso más notado que fue el
cierre parcial de la ciudad de Shanghai
donde se encuentra uno de los
principales puertos del país y también
del mundo sin evaluar datos
macroeconómicos ya los cierres que
forman parte de la política cero covite
del país provocaron enfrentamientos
entre empleados y las autoridades en las
afueras de la empresa focom una de las
contratistas que fabrica iphones en ese
país esto se presentó por que existen de
acuerdo con los trabajadores condiciones
inseguras en medio de todos estos brotes
Pero en cuanto a los datos económicos
los bloqueos están causando una caída en
el producto interno bruto de la nación
de acuerdo con la correduría nomura el
pronóstico de crecimiento pasó de un 2,8
a un 2,4% para el cuarto trimestre y al
tiempo que pasó de un 9 de un 2,9 un
2,8% para el año 2022 muy lejos del 5,5%
que estimado el gobierno para el
presente año vamos a cambiar de tema
hablamos de Rusia porque en ese país la
duma aprobó el presupuesto de la nación
para el 2023 además también fue revisado
y aprobado el presupuesto para el
período de planificación
2024-2025 pero centrándonos en 2023 de
acuerdo con la agencia de noticias
interfax los ingresos se estiman en 26
billones
130,3 mil millones de rublos el gasto
estará por el orden de los 29 billones
55,6 mil millones de rublos con un
déficit de dos billones
925,3 mil millones de rublos la
inflación de acuerdo con el gobierno
podría oscilar o tener un tope no más de
5,5%. nos venimos a nuestra región y nos
vamos hasta Brasil Porque en ese país se
analizan las estra para poder disminuir
los precios de los alimentos también hay
que señalar que están trabajando para
disminuir los precios de los
medicamentos de acuerdo con el senador
Humberto Costa coordinador del área de
la salud del equipo del presidente
electo Luis Ignacio Lula la Silva
informó que el nuevo gobierno pruebe
estimular la reindustrialización del
sector y llevar a cabo una reforma
fiscal para atraer a empresas
extranjeras a invertir en el país el
senado refiere que en la actualidad el
sector farmacéutico de la nación depende
de la importación de insumos y que
faltan incentivos para desarrollar la
biotecnología que podría aumentar la
eficacia de los medicamentos y también
abaratar sus costos como están los
indicadores económicos las acciones
globales subieron este día Aunque el
optimismo acerca de que la reserva
Federal pueda
mantenerse y abstenerse de subir
agresivamente las tasas de interés Se
dio contrarrestado por el cierta
incertidumbre sobre las restricciones
por coronavirus en China en Asia los
mercados cerraron de manera mixta del
día el índice de Shanghai fue el que
presentó números negativos a lo largo de
la jornada en Europa hubo números
positivos todo eso también impulsados
por la posibilidad de que no sea tan
agresiva la reserva Federal en el
aumento de las tasas y qué nos trae Luis
como cifra del día para finalizar ese
bloque económico tiene que ver en este
caso con los
740 millones de dólares en activos que
han sido recuperados luego de El quiebre
de la empresa ftx de esta empresa que
manejaba criptoactivos y así han ido
recuperando este dinero Gracias Luis
como siempre por toda la información
mañana más economía nosotros volamos
hasta París sin escalas para saludar a
nuestra periodista Erika olavarría